so you're malli fins or casting method
do you think that that helped save a
possible casting of saved online since
actors are so good and coming in and be
something that maybe they sense you want
them to be
and then you doing this sort of
detective work behind the scenes and
really sort of snuffing out sort of
someone really is do you think that
really helped save any casting mistakes
that that may
try that I I think so definitely because
I mean I always make one for every movie
I made one huge customer steak for some
reason it's always one person and there
was like oh I wish I hadn't any kind of
yeah try to rewrite stuff or kind of
zone that out but I mean the other thing
that you do is that you put the actors
together very soon you kind of get a
feeling for one person that you put two
lectures together and see how their
chemistry is and there you do the same
thing but the interesting things that
actors think the main part of their
audition is when the camera is actually
switched on but I think as a director
you get much more when the cameras
actually off you know and you are kind
of doing something and they are talking
I know the girl that I have in mind for
the main lead for the female and the guy
they are now just having coffee they
think they have two minutes off the
record and that's where you actually
listen and see their body language and
face and when you switch the camera that
you already know whether that's going to
work or not
you know so I think it's important that
you get these moments where they are
unguarded you know if they don't put on
show if they don't they don't already
create a character because with our
style I almost wanted to print t-shirt
that said no acting allowed you know I
didn't want them to create a character I
cast them for the character that I
wanted because with a manly fin method
you casting them for who they really are
so that you get all this artifice out of
the head and let them just emotionally
react to the situation the way they
would actually wear which is really hard
for actors to switch to because i think
they are so trained to create a
character and to do the step up and how
would this character react to the
situation but the problem is that it's a
very intellectual process you know your
goal I think as a director is always to
get them out of their heads and just
have them react without thinking about
it but that's really hard if they have
to
to think about what the character
mindset yeah so to get that out of the
way I think that way of auditioning
really helps
we all support from you that you believe
in giving actors freedom and you believe
in long takes
tell us about working with actors this
way
and the great advantage of the video you
know is that you have as many chicks as
your own especially in independent film
with other producers looking over your
shoulder in all the time restrictions in
other so you can do these long texts and
the great thing is that actors because
they are trained that where they'll come
in with a certain take on a seat they're
like I have an idea of how they want to
present that scene but in this technique
that we were using you immediately see
that because it's artificial because
that you know so you have to give them a
couple of takes to come to present their
idea and then they'll reach the point
where they are saying I don't know what
else to show you I've shown you
everything get all the ideas that I have
and then I know now it's getting good
because now they're out of ideas which
means there's nothing preconceived in
their head anymore they are going to
react
the moment that finally open to listen
to their scene partner because that's
the only impulse they are getting you
know and then you do that for a couple
of takes four five six legs or something
and then you reach the point where they
are so exhausted you know and their
thoughts and they are tired they are
angry at you because you're keeping them
there and they know that they have to
get to work or back to their fiance or
whatever and there is a tension that is
between them and you that translates
beautifully to the screen because as the
director I'm not appearing on the screen
so you the audience still sees that
tension but I think it's related to
something inside of the scene and sudden
you get subtle G in in their expressions
and in these moments where they're a
little it's just a little twitch
underneath there i I've always get it so
excited because you can't act that stuff
it's not if the actor now says I want a
twitch underneath my eye I don't know
that you could do that you have to
really get them into that situation
where their nerves are so all that that
stuff just happens you know that you
don't need a makeup artist that puts
sweat on them because they are swayed by
that one you know are they they really
need to go to the bathroom and you don't
let them you know everything
creates tension and some kind of inner
conflict I think does wonders in that
stuff
you